yeah I just wanted to stop yesterday and
take photos of this I mean look at that
it was just beautiful looking at the
mountains there were low clouds kind of
hanging in and out of the mountains
yesterday with dark clouds over the
valley but boy once the clouds cleared
these are the views that you're going to
get this morning so if you have a little
extra time you want to drive out towards
Red Rock go ahead take a few shots out
there it just looks glorious now if you
want to wait and go out maybe Friday
morning snow levels are going to be much
lower with this next system that's
coming through tomorrow into tomorrow
night and boy you might have some snow
like all the way down past the Red Rock
Visitor Center that's right we're
talking snow levels that might even go
down to 2500 feet temperatures are very
chilly this morning we're down in the
30s in quite a few neighborhoods 20's at
Red Rock teens in Kyle Canyon excuse me
teens for Reno Tonopah even below zero
up in Ely four below this morning with
20s for caliani Indian Springs freezing
in Pahrump 39 in Boulder City the winds
are starting to calm down a little bit
we had quite a few areas with Northwest
breezes but even those are starting to
relax thank goodness the next systems
dropping out of Canada not coming out of
here where the atmospheric Rivers were
for the last couple of weeks or so but
this is going to be colder air our Storm
from the beginning of the week is now
swirling into the Rockies and over into
the plains unfortunately thunderstorms
firing up in the plains probably going
to be some severe weather to deal with
there today let's run the futurecast
here we go once we get into Thursday
more clouds Thursday afternoon into
Thursday night we see the chance of
showers but also that cold air mixing
with the rain again could bring a little
bit of snow to Northwest Valley
neighborhoods West Side not that it's
going to stick because we don't expect a
whole lot but you might see a mix of
some rain and some snowflakes Thursday
night 29 up on the mountain today with
only low 20's for Lee Canyon please
dress warm if you're going to go to the
mountains gloves lots of insulated the
good jackets 53 for the high today our
normal is 59. enjoy the sunshine we'll
start seeing clouds tonight and that
chance of showers mainly midday through
the afternoon and tomorrow night you may
not be awake when it mixes with some
snow Thursday night but I bet the views
are going to be beautiful Friday morning
Breezy on Friday highs stay below normal
low 50s through the weekend and mornings
near freezing we're going to have some
cold mornings